well the judge has ruled Paul Manafort
lied repeatedly to the special counsels
office he could now spend the rest of
his life in prison a jury convicted man
afford of eight felonies including tax
and bank fraud back in August
one month later he pleaded guilty to two
more counts of conspiracy and agreed to
cooperate with the Russia investigation
in exchange for a lighter sentence the
judge's ruling means a special counsel
does not have to follow that agreement
Paula Reid is at the White House with
the potential impact and it could be big
Paula good morning that's right this is
significant bianna last year the special
counsels office accused men affort of
lying to them repeatedly about matters
at the heart of their investigation into
Russian meddling in the 2016 campaign
Manafort denied these allegations but
after a series of secret behind closed
doors court hearings judge Amy Berman
Jackson found that mana Ford did
intentionally lie about three of the
five things alleged by prosecutors and
that includes his contacts with an
associate known to have ties to Russian
intelligence services during the
campaign and after President Trump was
elected mana for is 69 years old as part
of his plea deal he faced up to 10 years
in prison in addition to his sentence
for those bank and tax fraud convictions
but by breaching his plea agreement he
now likely faces the rest of his life in
prison his only hope of avoiding that
fate is a presidential pardon and the
president has previously said that is
something he has not taken off the table
for Manta for he is scheduled to be
sentenced on March 13th
gaile all right Thank You Paula